A major milestone for NASA
Touchdown
has touchdown.
Space agency
finally has its hands
on an asteroid sample
seven years after launching to space
and NASA's spacecraft
delivered a capsule containing the sample
early on Sunday morning.
And we are told that that capsule
contains dust
and rocks from the asteroid.
Scientists will now spend years
studying the rare cosmic gift,
hoping to understand
the details about the origins
of the solar system.
With us
at the table, astrophysicist
Jan 11, Celso, professor of physics
and astronomy
at Barnard College
of Columbia University
and the author of the book
Black Hole Survival Guide.
Morning. Morning.
I geeked out
reading a lot on this morning.
It's super
interesting Phil
just wants to see the actual name
OSIRIS-REx. Yes.
Yeah, whatever that is.
It's a very long after now,
but it's amazing.
What it was able to do is incredible
because the material on this asteroid
we think is much more similar
to how the solar system
was when it first formed four
and a half billion years ago.
So it actually came from an asteroid belt
that's between Mars and Jupiter.
And we know we have this image
of asteroid belt just being very dense
and you can't navigate through.
But we've sent spacecraft through.
It's not that bad.
But it is dense enough
that there are collisions.
And this asteroid was cast out
and as now in a near Earth
orbit around the sun.
So we were able to get to it easily.
But it has this kind of ancient rock
and material.
What's the first thing?
So this they have this in hand.
Yeah, probably not literally
in your hands, but in summer
what are they doing right now?
Like this is a years long process,
I presume. Yes.
What are they first trying to find out?
So the first thing they've done is
they've moved it to a green room
locally in Utah where they collected it.
I should say.
The spacecraft
was about a third of the way to the moon
when it sent it to Earth, this capsule,
and then it jettisoned away.
So the capsule came on its own
and it was recovered and its £120.
So it was carried a first helicoptered
and then
put on a cart literally,
and then moved into the Johnson
Space Center in Houston.
Where it's going to be divvied up
a little bit
among scientists
and studied
to see
if there are these kind of precious
amino acids
that we think
might have launch to life here on Earth.
So it's unclear
if Earth had
what it takes to initiate life on its own
without asteroids
bringing material
to initiate the entire process.
Just by it sound like a dumb question.
How did it get the rocks in the dirt?
Like you've got this asteroid
and you've got this stuff.
Does it land scoop them up, take off?
It's a great question
because it's really quite small.
It's only a few hundred meters across,
and it's really more of
a kind of collection of debris
that's loosely stuck together,
a little bit of gravity.
And so what the spacecraft, it is
it dropped down really fast
and it stuck down a little probe
to kind of kick up dust, purposely
gather some material and pop off again.
And it didn't stay.
It was it was a flyby.
It was a drop, a punch.
And then it left and
and so it happened to get enough
material on it.
The whole thing turned out to be rockier
than we expected,
looser than we expected.
It really penetrated right into the soil.
So there wasn't any solid surface.
So even that part which happened in
20, 20 was quite amazing.
Yeah, it's remarkable.
How quickly
do you think people will have a sense of
if it has the answers
in terms of the amino acid,
it just jump in.
We do have theories, techniques to study
the amino acids to see
if water is killed inside.
But there are certainly probably
some tests and things
we haven't even thought of.
When we look at the Apollo mission
bringing back moon rocks,
we did not know there was water
trapped in these rocks
until 40 years later.
There were scientists
who hadn't been born
when the collections
were first made,
who invented techniques
to study them in the lab.
This is very much
if you hear the NASA scientists
talk about it,
they're saying in the future
there are scientists
not yet born who will study these rocks.
And it goes on now to do this again.
And another asteroid, right?
Yes.
It's on its way to another asteroid
and it won't be there until 20, 29.
Hey, I'll be watching.
Can I be watching
my thanks for having me.